hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well all right so
let's I think this is an example that's
very easy for students to relate to and
it's good to think of them there's a lot
of questions sort of rolled into it and
we often still approach I want you to
think about your own answers to these
sorts of things so let's sort of what is
it there and guidance first up you got
this guy ignite easy as a shepherd it
was actually a different story told
about him in Herodotus where the king
actually like brings have been to look
at his wife naked and you know the wife
finds out and says you got to kill the
king
this ring thing is something Plato made
up the rocketstor guy just doesn't fact
kill the King americlean it's a slightly
different story
in this point he's a shepherd he finds
this crevice and there's a ring in it
puts the ring out and guess what rings
I'm invisible and what's up that's what
it's so you know it's kind of a fairy
tale casting all right so what does he
do
first thing he does kills the king
marries a queen not a he's in charge and
he can do anything that he likes and why
is why is Glaucon bringing up the
what's really essential to it well
remember we're talking about justice and
injustice was it right for guide geez
you know the whole guide you story you
could maybe say yeah he was coerced
maybe it was the right thing for him to
do to kill the king
tell me I should tell you it so it's
just a weird story in the old story
right
the Herodotus story the king is his
friends with guy cheese and he says I
want you to see my wife naked I don't
want her to know that you're seeing
seeing her this is kind of like a trick
I'm gonna play on her so you're gonna
hide behind it it was the war or
something and just kind of look in she's
really really pretty
and it's sort of like guys a lot we're
talking about you know their girlfriends
or something like that sometimes you
hear it so I don't even see them so this
is that sort of thing and guy just
doesn't he comes in and forget exactly
what happens but somehow she figures out
he's there and so she says this is not
okay we're gonna change things that
you're either gonna kill the king or I'm
gonna add to each other so you've gotta
make a decision
so in that case guy juice you know
killing a king that's a bad thing
killing anybody it's a bad thing but you
can understand he was placed in this
situation when it's kill or be killed
and you could make me feel a bit more
sympathy for it's not so with Plato's
character I need to put something rang
says I can't I can't like to be king
I'll kill this guy I'll take his wife
now everything's great for me
he's an unjust guy he doesn't any sort
of you know I was under arrest
kind of Reason for what he does he just
he's doing bad things so what's a
central to the story the ring is somehow
connected
injustice because it does what what's up
sometimes yeah that's a key thing so the
ring man song it talks to you says are
you not for everybody else right
consequences are pretty bad for guide
use the King
there was the Queen likes well is there
anything else that's really essential to
this so it temps the person in a certain
way it takes away the consequences what
else is doing is you power this this
represents power in a very raw
unadulterated form that's why it's sort
of the fairy tale that because real
power is never like that as you guys get
older and you know you start making her
way up the ladder you know you'll be
saying yourself man I can't wait until I
get to be the boss then I'm not going to
have somebody else over me telling me
what to do yeah you know things will be
so much easier for me and then you
realize when you're actually in charge
exercising power is not quite as let's
see think it as there's lots of the
headaches like emilie's but in this
story there isn't right I mean if
somebody was a pain you could kill him
nobody didn't know and forget about
things like maybe you could throw dust
on the guy and catch
just just go with it story so you've got
this sort of raw power now think about
this
we don't have rings of invisibility is
there anything like that in our culture
that at least for some portion of time
or in certain circumstances gives people
something like that kind of power in our
culture yeah yeah money can buy you
immunity from effects you can use money
to corrupt the political process through
traditional process resource political
power can do it in certain respects some
may be celebrity could do although if
your celebrity the trouble is you're not
visible right
yeah or even if they don't believe it
you're part of your entourage they'll
tell a consistent story you know there's
there's some celebrities you can't go
places because they've done bad things
and like our Kelly over everyone's back
to Chicago he's in trouble or Polanski
comes back to the states he's he's in
trouble in most cases that it fails that
there's a lot of it that people live
yeah don't you put is more general money
to be an example of power and forces
resources resource it's very good yeah
yeah you know why does he find
killing of a witness such a
reprehensible thing compared to just you
know killing somebody in general because
it so corrupts the process you get a bad
person say a contract killer they kill
somebody else they finally get caught
you know and now there's witnesses to
that and the police are bringing a case
and that's some of the witnesses start
dying that person can't really be
touched they've gotten lately is there
anything else that you can think in
terms of technology these wrong
resources that's that's good what about
the internet gives people something
I'll say identity or sometimes no
identity at all anonymity any of you
read comments and all kind you tube
videos or logs or stuff like that
sometimes the comments will get our
intelligent debate going back and forth
how long that's been percentage one
person it's a in probably about right
and that's probably because you're
you're on you know fairly cerebral sites
you know if you just say if you're just
like what the ordinary person is not
maybe even must know one percent we're a
lot of the comments
yeah and people say horrible place you
know and then they say horrible things
to each other you know about the
families all sorts of that College of
the Nazi is quite often we call that
flaming right yeah there's a theory that
one of the reasons
yeah
exactly there's there's this notion that
there's a kind of like cloak of
invisibility given to the person because
you're done who can indulge whatever
their desires yeah let's see there's
flaming another trolling right what's
trolling so you literally go out of
somebody's site you say something
inflammatory to try to get that get a
rise out of them and then you know then
you say something even more inflammatory
why do people do this
well the parkus they can get away with
it because nobody's gonna call I mean
that you can kick somebody out of your
side
think about this one of the other
questions think about this what else is
like that you know our own culture other
things where somebody has afforded
anonymity or being free to the
consequences the same rules don't apply
to them as applied to people now what
would you do
yeah would you I think if we act
something to give this as a silence
people around like this I would cry you
know I would only do good things I would
I would like maybe take on walls but I
wouldn't take candy bars because that's
like a big thing there you know yeah
most of us you know if you actually gave
us a ring like this think about all the
fantasies desires that we have all the
things that we want you would be kind of
tough not to just go into any store and
take what you wanted think about the
people you don't like wouldn't it be
nice to go to walk up to them and like
trip them you know punch them in the
nose
they don't even see it coming or you
know we talked about this before like
you know business settings set up your
your competitors so that the report is
gonna you know they're gonna get up in
front of the loss of the big meeting and
all their stuff is gonna be screwed up
dude think about all the things that we
pretended I know I'm not a particularly
good person so I probably do a lot of
things now what would keep are there any
things you wouldn't do are there any
lines you wouldn't cross there would all
of you you know want to start killing
people settling scores stealing
everything under the Sun yeah okay
so not cuz we're as bad yeah I know I've
been still Michael you will I have it or
she'd be selected yeah I know I've been
angry enough in my life that if I had a
ring like that that's a that's a bad
thing that that's the case I think some
of us probably would be able to keep her
one of the one of the dangers and that
is rape you know maybe that would be
something anything else they you know
we'd all steal things
is there anything else you wouldn't do
alright now think about this you've got
a ring like that
what within you would keep you from
murder
you get one run you wouldn't need to
let's say somebody really ticked you off
and you people you've got the ring off
there's like kept on you know man this
person is just knocking well nobody
knows you're gathering that's what gives
you the power yeah murder is just the
process it's so much easier to walk into
a bank so I just like to play those
times of course you have a dedenne DNA
and all that service awesome so imagine
that somehow this this rain one also
wants automatically script DNA evidence
or something like that you know so it's
a get out of murder free card
yeah
you know in some cases that might
actually make it more like bully well
that's that's an interesting you know
I've never heard anyone bring up that
that sort of ideal but Amanda you've got
like an internalized well they're
worrying about that somebody would if
they knew that you have the training
you're doing those things would that be
enough to actually keep you from we're
doing some things at least yeah I think
Hubertus always prints positive he'd be
saying and I'll get into it but that
actually
okay I saw your your morale so there
this is what the ring of guy does gets
at is is there anything that would
actually hold you back from is there any
sort of role for moral compass now I
would say yeah you can do this but not
this or would the ring itself and being
so corrupting well we'll come back to
that question in long this what would
you be afraid other people do I mean not
everybody has that right you know some
people I think would you would
definitely not want to get a ring guy
just oh sure
good you know I used to teach in a
maximum-security prison
yeah there are guys who actually work
with them got to know really well who I
would be fine it's giving everyone guys
used to there are other guys in the
prison who just know ring of guy Jesus
at all I never want to see them out the
other guy living with them don't ever
want to see them get out so there are
some real you know evil people out there
and just imagine the things that they do
now there's a gap right you're not that
person put that ring out long enough
would there be kind of a process that
would lead you into becoming that person
this is this actually starts looking a
lot like a different room that's
different fantasy right anyone see any
connections
Lord of the Lord of the Rings is that
has the wondering right what does that
one ring dim bring to credible power not
only does attorney invisible lets you do
all sorts of other stuff what else
yeah they want because they want that
that superpower we got what did he lose
it over was he trying to protect but
what do you think Sam is he getting that
Sam right what do you think Sam was
trying to do right if you've got that
sort of power that's where the power
makes you desire to hold on to that sort
of power and use that sort of power as
well the ring of guide juice is supposed
to tell us something about egoism it's
supposed to tell us that if we actually
had this sort of power
none of us could really be trusted
unless there's something in us because
it and having morals or sometimes you
talk about my conscience you kind of
conscience some sort of core to us that
would actually say no but you can't go
and you can't do this this is wrong now
if your if your understanding of justice
is something purely instrumental it's
only good for getting under things
that's not going to be back is it this
thing about worrying about what somebody
else might say that might actually be on
the right track thinking about how you
would periods of others I know that that
could that could work for me how you
appear to yourself would you
after months and months nothing about it
some people when I asked them about this
do you think about that our life yeah
first time just like steal gumballs
but then I'd probably start stealing
other stuff and then I starts doing
other stuff and then maybe start killing
people because I know the kind of person
that I have when somebody lets me get
away with something I tend to want to
get away with more and more and more
this is that a common human thing that's
a problem for me I think it's a pretty
kind so the question that you'd have to
think about that what could actually
keep you from wondering really nobody
can be trusted with so what's a whole
you know book series about destroying
the ring getting rid of that kind of
power because it's not even you know
there's there's how maybe you read The
Lord of the Rings always watch the
movies so I'll leave you with this look
there are some really key points in that
series where certain people are tempted
to take the ring and don't do it and
they are people who are very wise I can
think of at least two there's Gandalf
and Gandalf hesitates doesn't mean many
things about me if I had this ring I
could do so many good things but that's
sort of the thing is not going to
actually keep keep going on it's gonna
erupt and then there's I forget her name
as an elf lady
they Tolkien scholar yeah she is tempted
isn't she
Lisa the movie I'm not sure if it's over
she doesn't why not because she
recognizes she has enough wisdom to
recognize this was properly
I can't I'm not a good enough person I'm
a good enough person to recognize that
I'm not a good enough person to
withstand comments you know what are
they really about eating drinking
hanging out they're not about like world
power nomination you know I don't know
much about Tolkien is like ideas for
starting and some sort of you may know a
lot more than I do
yeah it's I think there is something to
what you're saying about the hobbits be
in some sense more innocent but you
notice that that Frodo is like willing
to kill Sam protecting
they then column is something sort of
like that Hobbit originally and then
look at what it turns into
after years and years of being subjected
to not quite exactly the same thing is
we're gonna guide you put the ring of
guidance and I have it similarly so what
we're thinking